you've been coming on this show for I
don't know 15 years or something 1898 I
think was the first time for the faculty
oh is that true okay you came on and and
we were saying you have not changed I
you are the most you in and it's almost
scary you're not aging at all and I Andy
and I are Andy and I are creeped out by
[Laughter]
because we are falling apart fast you're
definitely not oh yes we are
the Irish Age we were old weird junk
trees we grow quickly and then we just
crumble no we've had so much work done
both of us have be creative we finally
started to get work done but we got
really cheap work that's what Andy and I
would do when it's time for us to get
plastic surgery we would go and get the
cheapest kind first line yeah we'd find
someplace it's like I don't know we
haven't done this before but we'll give
it a shot well I got it I got a Groupon
yeah and then you'd come on the show it
would be like it's good to see you
exactly okay so but I don't know if you
have is this just your genes you think
it's your destiny my destiny is to never
age I
yeah I mean I guess it is genetic I've
always looked younger than I am
I remember that when I was really young
wanting to do parts that I didn't look
old enough for and feeling you know
younger than I really was and wanting to
get older and I I'm 36 now and I don't
look 36 I still get carded I still get
Carl absolutely every alcohol i orb or
cigarettes I get carded smoke it's it
yeah
yeah that's a booth design kids yeah but
no cigarettes have you sit by the way
have you seen Andy's very popular PSA
booze is fine fine okay loses fine kids
now get out
you